coming to a close now is the perfect
time to look back at the most surprising
most terrifying and most awe-inspiring
episodes of the year
you pop out of the ocean and hear the
faint yells of the Lifeguard the whole
Beach panics
you turn around
something lurks in the water
before you can say Loch Ness monster a
tall Shadow emerges lunging with its
sharp teeth headed your way
if the stixosaurus were around today
where would it live
what would your potential demise have to
do with being crushed by stones
and why could it be more afraid of you
than you'd be a vet
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the stixosaurus was alive
technically speaking this Marine reptile
wasn't a dinosaur although it sure swam
the Earth alongside many of them
stixosaurus lived 70 to 85 million years
ago in the late Cretaceous Period long
before humans set foot on the planet
and this monstrosity measured 10 meters
in length
its prominent neck accounted for close
to half that size at five meters that's
almost three times longer than the neck
of the average giraffe and this freak of
nature was no lightweight either with
more than 3 600 kilograms of reptilian
goodness it was as heavy as a killer
whale
so how come this enormous reptile
wouldn't swallow you whole
scientists have found fossils of this
ancient Behemoth in what is now Kansas
and South Dakota
so if stixxosaurus were alive today it
would mainly inhabit the coasts of North
America
but it's unlikely you'd see this beast
in its full size
all you'd be able to spot is its head
and a good chunk of its long neck
protruding from the water
that's because stixxosaurus would bury
its large turtle-like body in the
murkiest and darkest Waters making it
appear much smaller than it actually is
this would reduce the chances of it
being detected and would make it seem
less intimidating to the fish and Squid
it will later munch on
this feasting would be pulled straight
from a horror movie
as styxasaurus shut its mouth around its
prey sharp teeth would intermesh with
each other and fully trap the animal
inside
like a cage from which there's no
escaping
but the process wouldn't quite end there
some of the stixxosaurus fossils were
found with over 200 small stones in
their bellies
these Stones could have served as a
ballast helping the prehistoric
creatures sink closer to the ocean floor
but it's more likely that the Rocks
aided with digestion
yeah while the teeth of the stixosaurus
evolved for seizing slippery prey they
weren't particularly effective at
cutting through flesh
so this Behemoth would swallow its still
living prey whole and the stones in its
belly would take care of crushing bones
and rubbing off scales
now if it set its eyes on you would you
end up rocking and rolling in its
stomach
well the head of an average stixxosaurus
would be around 50 centimeters long with
a snout of about 30 centimeters in
length that means if you happen to be an
average sized adult this sea reptile
wouldn't want to try swallowing you
whole
you wouldn't fit in its mouth
now if stixxasaurus could swallow you
whole you'd experience a sudden
inescapable Darkness as you slide down a
long neck and land in a stone pit
and that's where you'd finally be
pummeled to death with rocks
what a bizarre way to go
it's a good thing this Behemoth wouldn't
be big enough to swallow you in one
piece
but this doesn't mean you'd go
completely unharmed
the stixxosaurus might be trying to take
a bite out of you in self-defense your
best bet for surviving would be to do
what you would do during a shark attack
the worst thing you could do is panic
and splash around
that would only Peak the stixosaurus's
Curiosity Instead try to look as big and
intimidating as you possibly can
of course that's easier said than done
when facing a predator 45 times your
size
if you managed to gain the
stixxosaurus's respect and it left you
alone it could settle for the smaller
portion options
but sticking to fish and Squid would
make it run into some Fierce competition
namely sharks and killer whales who also
gorge on similar sea life
but here's a twist
with this potential swimming buffet
around the oceanic predators of today
might add a new item to their menu and
this would be you guessed it a generous
serving of styxasaurus
that's because this giant reptile was
never really the apex predator it's
intimidating appearance might suggest
prehistoric sharks with a size similar
to the modern great white were
stixxosaurus's natural-born enemy and
very likely aided in its Extinction
and on top of being hunted by ancient
sharks it seems like the stixxosaurus
also wasn't immune to the temperature
changes in the ocean that were brought
on by the changing climate
yikes our long neck friend could not
have chosen a worse time to stick around
but here's a Twist it's actually how
cold the oceans currently are that might
give the stixosaurus trouble
during the Cretaceous Period the
planet's oceans had an average
temperature of 37 degrees Celsius
the stixxosaurus will have a real hard
time withstanding the cooler Waters that
can be found off North American coasts
today
unless it had adapted through Evolution
not even warmer tropical waters would be
able to provide its sufficient Heat
if the stixxosaurus was around today it
might not pose the greatest of threats
to us ocean-loving humans
if anything the risk to this behemoth's
survival would go beyond killer whales
and sharks
yeah you can bet our more avant-garde
Foodies would also be dying to give
styxasaurus a taste
[Music]
this Former Intelligence officer turned
president took Russia from a defeated
Cold War Relic to the most feared
superpower in Eurasia now Vladimir Putin
who many have called a modern day Adolf
Hitler is dead
the consequences will be dire
who would replace Putin
could his death stop the war in Ukraine
and why could this lead to Civil War in
Russia
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Putin died
a former KGB agent Vladimir Putin likes
to project what he considers to be a
masculine image
reports state that his obsession with
returning Russia to the former Glory
Days of the USSR dominate his mind as he
moves forward with this plan
Putin controls Russian television where
70 percent of the population receives
its news his administration is known for
censoring information on the internet
Putin even changed the nation's laws to
give himself another two terms as
president
that means he could be in power until
2036 when he'll be 84 years old
his quest for power led him to invade
Ukraine causing the murder of innocent
civilians including children
this regime has also targeted the
biggest nuclear power plant in Europe
so if this apparent dictator for Life
died today
how would his replacement deal with the
war in Ukraine
well with the Russian despot declared
dead Russia would experience a power
vacuum not seen since the death of
another Russian Terror ruler Joseph
Stalin in 1953
oligarchs and politicians would seek to
latch onto whatever they could grab so
who gets first dibs on Putin's empty
seat
immediately Power would transfer to
Prime Minister Michael
this interim president would rule for 90
days until the next election
this would be more than enough time for
those closest to Putin to consolidate
their power
you see Putin was Russia's last elected
official
and once in office he placed his loyal
supporters in key positions and
destroyed his political enemies people
like opposition leader Alexei navalny
who ran for office and organized
anti-government demonstrations were
thrown in jail
so much for a free and fair election
now without a central figure in charge
the autocrats could start playing out
real-life Game of Thrones scenarios as
they juggle forces and plan coups
against each other
but
mean for Russia's current war in Ukraine
when covid-19 spread worldwide Putin's
popularity at home hit new lows
but his invasion of Ukraine has created
a nationalistic fever dream
skyrocketing his approval rating to a
staggering 69 percent
claimed that Ukraine's move to join NATO
posed a major threat to Russia's
security
despite this High approval rating and
Decades of propaganda
51 percent of Russians believe that the
two Nations should remain independent
whoever took the mantle next would have
a tough decision on whether to continue
pro-putin policies or start a new
chapter in international relations
however this war could bring several
other unknown factors into play
for one if Putin didn't hand pick a
successor before passing a military
official could try to grab power
that might put Russia's Armed Forces
chemical weapons and nuclear Firepower
into even more unstable hands
without the dictator in charge anymore
keeping a country this size together
might be impossible and that could give
the United States and the European Union
the chance to crush Russia's economy
after Russia attacked Ukraine the world
responded by attacking Putin with
economic sanctions
the ruble dropped in value to less than
one U.S Cent
the Swift banking system cut off many
Russian Banks from using their services
that means transactions adding up to
trillions of dollars stopped processing
some Airlines won't even accept Russian
Nationals aboard their planes and dozens
of countries have already closed their
airspace to Russian flights
Russians are now practically trapped in
their own country they can't travel to
Europe they can't buy iPhones their
savings are dropping every day and it's
not just the upper class feeling the
Heat
over half the Russian population lives
on six thousand dollars or less per year
a falling standard of living and a
failing economy could give rise to a new
opposition party
maybe jailed leader navalny would be
released to lead this new wave with
Putin gone
but sanctions and bans wouldn't just
hurt Russia with so much fuel and oil
exported from this country gas prices
would rise to unseen levels
Russia accounts for 30 percent of all
the world's exports in grains used in
cereals and don't forget all the gems
iron and precious metals they export
the world would need to figure out how
to keep the supply chain running after
cutting off Russia
no matter who took the reins the
pressure mounting on all sides could be
enough to get Russia to pull out of
Ukraine it's hard to continue a war when
you don't have any money
and even if a figure came along with the
presence of Putin who wanted to continue
his brand of politics
Russia would have to consider embracing
the West again instead of facing a world
of isolation and ever increasing poverty
with Russia backed into a corner they
could be forced to give up territories
that once belonged to other countries
Putin's annexation of Crimea and donbass
could end and returning these lands to
Ukraine could restore Pride to the
people living in this illegally
fractured Nation
if those harsh economic policies and
sanctions remained in Russia the
conditions on the ground could create
unrest that could turn into an all-out
Rebellion
whoever inherits this mask would be in
for a long period of rebuilding a
tattered society and renewing Global
Trust
ukrainians could only hope for a new
period of Peace after the death of Putin
and the fall of the Russian economy
[Music]
universe
nothing gets colder than that
so if the entire Earth suddenly cooled
down to the most frigid temperature for
even five seconds it would reek a lot of
havoc
just how cold is absolute zero
what would happen to your body at this
temperature
and what's the coolest thing about it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth dropped to absolute
zero for five seconds
temperature is how we measure kinetic
energy of the particles in any object
yeah it tells us how fast atoms
molecules and particles move
the hotter a gas liquid or solid gets
the faster the particles move and when
that movement slows down the colder that
substance becomes at the lowest
temperature possible or absolute zero
particles stop moving altogether
this is because at zero Kelvin or minus
273.15 degrees Celsius no heat energy
Remains the coldest ground temperature
ever on earth
184 Kelvin or minus 89.2 degrees Celsius
was recorded in Antarctica in 1983 but
it doesn't even come close to absolute
zero
even the coldest known place in the
entire universe the boomerang nebula 5
000 light years away from Earth is just
a tad warmer at one Kelvin
so are you ready for the coldest five
seconds ever
[Music]
at room temperature you know that
comfortable range of temperatures of
about 293 Kelvin the air molecules move
at an average speed of 1800 kilometers
per hour
as the temperatures on Earth suddenly
plummeted all those particles would slow
down
at
0.00001 Kelvin the atomic particles
would be moving at a speed of about
0.18 kilometers per hour
that's 1 000 times slower than their
speed at room temperature
getting this close to absolute zero All
chemical reactions would be closer and
closer to coming to a complete stop
and this would be very bad news for you
and everything else on Earth
chemical reactions are responsible for
everything including how your brain
communicates with your body
without the trillions of chemical
reactions going on inside of you you
wouldn't be able to breathe or turn food
into fuel
temperatures near absolute zero would be
devastatingly cold even at a
comparatively toasty 77 Kelvin you'd be
in serious trouble
that's the temperature of liquid
nitrogen
after just a few seconds of exposure to
this temperature you'd suffer severe
burns blistering and Frostbite needing a
toe or 10 amputated could be could be
definite possibility
so just five seconds of absolute zero
could do incredible amounts of damage to
all life forms on Earth
but I have good news
the chemical reactions wouldn't come to
a total standstill
even at the near absolute zero
temperature of the boomerang nebula
chemical reactions do still appear to
take place
this is thanks to the strange effects of
quantum physics
and whenever quantum physics is involved
things get weird
with all the atoms on Earth at a near
standstill you'd find them starting to
Clump together they'd be forming a state
of matter known as a Bose Einstein
condensate
this would mean that every atom is in
the same energy State and essentially
identical to one another from a physical
point of view
they'd start to behave as a single atom
and if you could become a Bose Einstein
condensate it would be pretty cool
pardon the pun
for those brief five seconds you'd have
some unique physical properties like
superfluidity
yeah you'd be able to flow through tiny
cracks without any friction only there
wouldn't be any cracks because you
wouldn't be the only super fluid thing
on the planet
but there is a catch
Bose Einstein condensates can only be
formed when bosons are cooled to near
absolute zero bosons are all atoms with
an even number of electrons
that means only some of the atoms in
your body and the environment around you
could become a Bose Einstein condensate
and lucky for you reaching a temperature
of absolute zero wouldn't be possible
if Earth and everything on it plummeted
to absolute zero it would instantly pull
the heat from the space around it
to keep you and the planet at zero
degrees Kelvin even for five seconds
you'd need an infinite amount of
resources
this makes it mathematically impossible
but that wouldn't mean that five seconds
of near absolute zero temperatures
wouldn't destroy just about everything
and nothing would ever come back
together from this soup of atoms that
you and the entire planet would turn
into
behind you a colossal hurricane moments
away from making landfall
in front of you a towering tornado fast
tracking its way toward the opposing
storm and you
times run out Escape
is futile
would these two storms merge into a new
kind of catastrophe
how much would it be capable of
destroying
and can you survive this Clash of wind
Titans
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a tornado hit a hurricane
's are formed when a weather disturbance
such as a thunderstorm moves across an
Ocean warmer than 26.5 degrees
the storm pulls in hot and humid air
from the warm Waters and condensation
continuously feeds the hurricane with
more and more clouds
cooler air rushes in to fill up the low
air pressure Zone left by all that hot
air being forced upward creating
ferocious winds in the process
a category 5 hurricane the biggest among
them has a wind speed of
252 kilometers per hour
and it brings with it the potential for
catastrophic damage backed by storm
surges as high as eight meters
and then you have a tornado these are
rotating Columns of wind extending from
the ground all the way up to a
thunderstorm
every one of them requires a supercell
to form also known as a giant storm
tornadoes can stretch as wide as 460
meters and although they tend to last
less than 10 minutes on average their
destructive winds can be well over 320
kilometers per hour
so what would it look like if these two
literal Airbenders collided
a big part of this showdown would come
down to which of these two is more
powerful
in terms of pure might a tornado's winds
can be stronger than A hurricane's and
yet hurricanes unlike tornadoes last for
days instead of just minutes
there are also much larger and tend to
cause a lot more damage
it's also not uncommon for tornadoes to
form from hurricanes and their giant
thunderstorms
if you were trapped in a really big
Tempest you could even witness what
seems like a whole group of tornadoes
colliding with each other merging and
breaking apart
that's what scientists call a
multi-vortex tornado it's a single
tornado that has formed anywhere from
two to five funnel clouds rotating
around each other
on the other hand hurricanes could
technically come in contact with each
other if two of them end up less than
1500 kilometers apart they may start to
rotate around each other in what's known
as the fujiwara effect or more fittingly
the fujiwara dance
now if two hurricanes come within 300
kilometers of each other the stronger
one can absorb the smaller one
this is what happened in 1995 when
hurricane Iris and tropical storm Karen
came in close contact
the two rotated I mean danced around
each other before the tougher Iris
swallowed poor Karen
but let's get to the encounter we're all
here for a tornado and a hurricane
meeting Head to Head
what would it feel like to witness their
Clash
well as the hurricane was approaching
you you'd see a rainstorm it would be
accompanied by strong winds and the
Eerie sound of early warning sirens
the gusts of wind would build up until
they roared only yelling would allow you
to communicate with others
sooner rather than later you'd have a
hard time remaining on your feet trees
would bend break and even be ripped
straight out of the ground
roofs would be torn off in your
neighborhood and fly away like paper
airplanes along with that car you've yet
to pay off
oh bye bye
I mean not that you'd be able to witness
it the rain would be coming down so hard
it would be nearly impossible to see
anything at all
and then you'd see it the massive
tornado
as they got closer the two storms would
start to orbit around each other in an
epic fujiwara dance off
this swirling Whirlwind of an encounter
between destructive foes would then end
with two possible outcomes
the tornado and the hurricane splitting
apart from their dance and going their
own way or the sheer size of the
hurricane absorbing the tornado vortex
oh which I'm sorry to say wouldn't be
too exciting the tornado's funnel would
just dry up and go back into the clouds
in this case the hurricane would emerge
the winner
but despite the power of its former
dance partner the Hurricane's Victory
wouldn't even make it any stronger
remember hurricanes can only feed
themselves from warm ocean water not
from other storms like tornadoes not
that it means you're out of danger you'd
still better hurry and take shelter
otherwise you'd go flying through the
air alongside all those newly destroyed
rooftops and although we didn't end up
witnessing uh tornado the sight of
either of these natural disasters should
tell you it's time to Run for Cover
from space it would look like Earth had
a giant pimple
smack dab in the middle of Brazil
back on the ground you'd be astonished
by the enormity of Olympus Mons the
tallest mountain in our solar system
which also happens to be a massive
volcano
if this Martian Colossus was located in
South America
how catastrophic would its eruption be
why would you never experience an
earthquake
and why would countries start wars over
this epic Mountain
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Olympus Mons was located in
South America
no other mountain in our solar system
rises above the 25 kilometer height of
Olympus Mons to put that into
perspective Olympus is over two and a
half times taller than Mount Everest and
this flat top giant isn't only tall it's
also really wide
on Earth the base of Olympus Mons would
cover Ecuador entirely
but here's a twist for a volcano this
large to form on our planet Earth would
need some big changes under its crest
deep in our planet's mantle there are
areas that are unusually hot
these are known as hot spots from these
hot spots large amounts of magma rise
breaking through the Earth's crust
and that's how volcanoes are formed
but because Earth's crust is made up of
moving tectonic plates a volcano will
eventually move away from the hot spots
that formed it and as such stop growing
that's why a volcano as large as Olympus
Mons could never be formed on the earth
we know today
the reason why Mars is able to house
more massive volcanoes is that unlike
our planet it doesn't have these moving
tectonic plates
this means that on Mars volcanoes remain
on top of their hot spot and continue
growing
now take away the earth's tectonic
plates and we could grow our own Olympus
Mons
and on the bright side no tectonic
plates would mean no earthquakes ever
and we'd likely still live on the first
supercontinent rodinia
that's because the plates wouldn't move
and break the land into separate
continents like we have now
on the not so bright side this super
volcano could cause some damage
how long would we have before it rained
fire and Ash all over Humanity
well not all volcanoes are the same and
we might have a chance to survive
Olympus Mons erupting
so you shouldn't judge a book by its
cover or a mountain by its size
Olympus Mons is a shield volcano that
means it doesn't chaotically spew melted
rock out causing planetary destruction
in the process when volcanoes like
Olympus Mons erupt it usually isn't a
violent explosion
instead they tend to produce a steady
and long-lasting flow of lava and that's
good news lava flows are easy to spot
predict and avoid
so there wouldn't be a catastrophic
apocalypse when Olympus Mons went off
it might not even have a Major Impact
when it comes to climate change
that's because shield volcanoes don't
release much gas or debris
lucky you
and just to sweeten the deal Olympus
Mons wouldn't erupt today
the last time would have been between 20
and 200 million years ago
the dinosaurs wouldn't have fared so
well though many would have died due to
constant volcanic eruptions
but wait there's more
living around Olympus Mons could bring
you lots of cash
that's because the ground around this
Grand volcano's base would be rich with
minerals from its basaltic magma
including magnesium
this would seriously improve the quality
of agricultural soil time to get into
the agricultural business
and that's not all even if the volcano
is active it creates geothermal energy
just like some cities in the United
States currently generate electricity
from smaller volcanoes
and you can bet it would be a year-round
tourist attraction
but now hold off on your Victory lap an
Earthly Olympus Mons would bring some
problems with it man-made problems to be
precise
volcanoes produce natural resources like
diamonds gold and nickel so naturally
South American countries that share
portions of Olympus Mons would see a
steep increase in wealth
and like history has shown violent and
destructive conflicts over these
resources would be inevitable just like
diamonds fueled civil wars in Africa
which lasted over a decade and left
thousands dead
South America's long history of social
and political unrest would be aggravated
by Olympus monza's Treasures
around it blood could flow much more
commonly than lava
make room Earthling we're moving the
other planets in our solar system into
our planetary neck of the woods
would all the planets fit into this
Goldilocks zone
what kinds of gravitational chaos would
this cause
and does this mean life would exist on
the other planets
this is what if and here's what would
happen if all the planets of the solar
system were in the habitable zone
liquid water is a key ingredient for
life and in our solar system earth is
the only planet with liquid water on its
surface
that's because our planet is located in
the habitable zone of our sun also known
as the Goldilocks zone
and the conditions here are just right
any closer and water would boil away any
further it would freeze
the size of this area depends on how hot
or cool a star is
scientists have discovered 4 000
exoplanets within habitable zones but
only 24 of them might be able to support
life
in our solar system this zone is within
a range of 0.9 to 1.2 astronomical units
from the Sun
so if we parked all the other planets
within this 45 million kilometer patch
of real estate could we Kickstart
extraterrestrial life
with eight planets to squeeze in the
Goldilocks zone you'd need to get
creative
the last thing you'd want to do would be
disrupt the conditions for life on Earth
right well to start this scenario off
you'd need to move Mercury to the
innermost portion of the habitable zone
at around 0.9 astronomical units that
would be more than twice as far away
from the Sun as Mercury orbits now
much would change on this rocky planet
except for a refreshing coolness after
billions of years of scorching hot
temperatures
Venus already orbits relatively close to
the habitable zone at 0.72 astronomical
units when our son was a young star and
dimmer Venus was essentially located in
the habitable zone
it could even have had conditions for
life with a shallow ocean of its own
but as the sun got hotter that
Goldilocks zone was pushed further back
temperatures increased and the oceans
boiled away
maybe relocating Venus to a cooler spot
away from the Sun could make it
habitable once again
now it would be time to do some
calculating you've got five more planets
to squeeze in it could be a good idea to
make sure all the planets are an equal
distance apart
with our narrow Goldilocks zone you
could place each planet six and a half
million kilometers from each other
that would be equal to about 30 times
the distance between the Earth and the
Moon
moving us away from our current location
would make this whole experiment a
little less chaotic but at about 0.97
astronomical units
things would get warmer here
bad news for the climate crisis
uh ignoring that for now you'd move on
to Mars
you'd be excited to see if this cold
rocky planet could have life
well sorry to say it would still be
barren
you see liquid water isn't the only
thing that life needs to thrive Mars
lacks a magnetic field
that means solar radiation would strip
away the chances of it having an
atmosphere you'd still have to terraform
it
you'd likely not see any life popping up
on the remaining gaseous planets either
the gas giants Jupiter and Saturn have
atmospheric pressures and temperatures
far too intense for molecules like DNA
to be stable
but you could probably take a cold dip
on one of Jupiter's moons Europa its new
proximity to the sun would allow its
thick ice layer to melt
feeling refreshed you'd realize that the
last planet in our solar system Neptune
is now even closer to us than Mars is
today
that means in our new solar system
Arrangement Planet hopping would be a
reasonable Adventure
even with current technology you could
travel between the planets in 90 days
and Beyond the exploration there are all
kinds of resources you could extract
from the other planets you could get
hydrogen fuel from Jupiter and Saturn to
help us transition to a low-carbon
future
you could mine Cobalt from asteroids
this would be important to developing
Renewable Energy Systems
but this new solar system would be a
little unstable to say the least
especially with a massive Planet like
Jupiter so close to us it has two and a
half times the mass of all the other
planets in our solar system combined
scientific reports indicate a star
similar to our sun could have six
earth-sized planets within its habitable
zone
with Jupiter gravitational stability
would be all out of whack and all these
imbalances could result in the planets
or moons getting ejected from orbit or
reshuffled completely
whoa watch your head some seriously big
asteroids are crashing into Earth
what kind of shapes and sizes do they
have
which ones would have the deadliest
impact
and which one would be most likely to
hit
oh get your bunker ready
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the largest asteroid hit Earth
okay let's get the terminology out of
the way I say asteroids but
subjects on our list are not asteroids
they're comets
both asteroids and comets are objects in
our solar system but they aren't the
same
asteroids are rocky leftovers from the
early formation of our planetary
neighborhood and of the over one million
that we know of most orbit the Sun in
the asteroid belt between Mars and
Jupiter
on the other hand comets are snowballs
made of Frozen gases Rock and dust
they orbit the Sun and when they get too
close they start to melt
this releases a giant cloud of dust and
gas that can be larger than most planets
with 3 000 known comets in the solar
system
could a few be ready to turn the earth
into a giant cloud of dust too
[Music]
meteorite
foreign let's start with a smaller
object that has already hit our planet
meet the chelyabin's meteorite it
exploded over Russia in February of
2013.
with a diameter of about 17 meters that
was relatively small but the impact was
huge
the explosion had the energetic
equivalent of 500 000 tons of TNT
that's about 30 times as powerful as the
bomb that was dropped on Hiroshima it
injured 1200 people and caused enormous
property damage
pretty big effects from a little
extraterrestrial visitor
chicks Lube
moving on to something bigger we'll go
65 million years into the past
the massive chicks Lube asteroid was
likely one of the forces that resulted
in the mass extinction of the Dinosaurs
it was about 10 to 15 kilometers wide
and its impact crater in Mexico's
Yucatan Peninsula measures
180 kilometers wide and 900 meters deep
whoa
when this asteroid slammed into Earth it
devastated everything nearby the blast
wave sent enormous amounts of Rocky
material into the atmosphere and it
caused tsunamis as high as 1500 meters
while all the soot didn't completely
block out the sun it reduced the amount
of sunlight reaching the surface of our
planet
that seriously devastated plant growth
and had Rippling consequences on the
food chain
eventually it caused entire ecosystems
to collapse
omuamua
of all the objects that could collide
with us omuamua has one of the more
interesting shapes
this rocky cigar-shaped object is about
400 meters in length
NASA classifies it as a comet but it
exhibits traits of an asteroid too and
it doesn't have an attachment to any
star system so we don't know where in
space it originates from
2017 it passed by the Earth at a
distance of 41 million kilometers
now while we were safe from impact on
that occasion it could have resulted in
a lot of Destruction
if this Interstellar guest crashed into
Earth Darkness would cover our planet
and if the dust and debris stayed in our
atmosphere for a long time it would kill
many plants animals and humans that
depend on the Sun
bennu
bennu is not only an asteroid you should
worry about it's the asteroid you should
worry about
it has a one in 1700 chance of colliding
with Earth in September of the Year 2182
at only half a kilometer wide It's
relatively small but remember how
significant the chelyabin's impact was
yeah with that in mind you might be a
little nervous when it makes a close
approach to Earth every six years
Shoemaker Levy nine
this next Comet doesn't have any chance
of hitting Earth that's because it
already collided with Jupiter in 1994.
but you could imagine the destruction
this one and a half to two kilometer
wide comet would have caused on our home
turf
it broke into 20 pieces as a result of
Jupiter's gravity
the collisions from these fragments were
so powerful that they were similar to
the detonations of about 300 million
atomic bombs
plumes of debris shot as high as 2 000
to 3 000 kilometers
and the atmosphere heated to scorching
temperatures of 30 000 to 40 000 degrees
you must be pretty relieved that
Shoemaker Levy 9 never hit us
[Music]
series
last but far from the least is an
asteroid so big it's technically
classified as a dwarf planet
Ceres is the largest object in the
asteroid belt it makes up 25 of the
belt's total mass
the radius of series is
476 kilometers
that makes it over 60 times larger than
our ancient friend chicksloob
if Ceres collided with Earth
there wouldn't just be Devastation there
would be no Earth
the size of series alone would block out
the Sun as it approached and then the
impact would remove 10 kilometers of the
Earth's crust
Hypersonic shock waves would Ripple
across the globe
everything in its path would be
incinerated and leveled nothing would
stand a chance of surviving
our planet would essentially turn into a
glowing ball of fire and melted rock
if by some miracle or secret underground
bunker you survived well you wouldn't
last long
soot in the atmosphere would result in
something like a nuclear winter
foreign
[Music]
635 light years from where you are
sitting way out there in outer space
lies a planet
the first planet to be discovered within
the habitable zone of a sun-like star
its name is Kepler-22b
when a planet is located within a star's
habitable zone it means there's a chance
that liquid water exists on its surface
and where there's water there's also the
possibility of life
human life
how long would it take to get to Kepler
22b
what would the weather be like over
there
and why would you need to get jacked
before arriving on this new planet
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you live on Kepler-22b
Kepler-22b is what scientists call an
exoplanet it's a planet outside our
solar system
spotting an exoplanet like Kepler-22b is
often not easy
the bright glare of the Stars they orbit
tends to keep them hidden from our
telescopes
what did scientists come up with to get
around it
looking at the stars themselves to see
if they can find anything unusual about
them they spotted Kepler-22b using
What's called the transit method they
watched Kepler 22 the star this
exoplanet orbits around and noticed that
its brightness changes over time
that was because
Kepler-22b was blocking the star's light
with this scientists were able to learn
both the size of 22b and how it orbits
and it looks like this distant Space
Rock could become our next home
okay but what do we really know about
Kepler-22b
its mass is 36 times that of Earth with
a radius of two and a half times larger
than ours one year on Kepler-22b is 290
days
it's also located 15 closer to its star
than we are to the Sun
if Earth scooched over that close to our
star
fried
Kepler-22b on the other hand is lucky to
have a son that is remarkably similar to
ours but also smaller and cooler this
close proximity to its star allows the
planet to receive about the same amount
of sunlight as we get over here the
temperature on Kepler-22b could be about
15 to 22 degrees Celsius
similar to Earth's Spring weather and
quite habitable if you ask me
but our galaxy can be a cruel place and
not everything is good news
some models suggest Kepler-22b is
rotating on its side kind of like our
very own Uranus
this may sound insignificant but it adds
potentially deadly complications this
would mean that it's North and South
poles are shrouded in either Darkness or
sunlight for half a year
and this ain't simply a matter of
whether you're a daytime or a nighttime
person a world like Kepler-22b spinning
on its side means that temperatures
could change from boiling to freezing
which wouldn't be great for human life
I know what a bummer but don't despair
yet because our galaxy is also big
enough to include some hope
studies suggest that Kepler-22b might be
covered in an ocean 50 meters deep and
that ocean would be able to act as
natural climate control keeping the wild
temperatures at Bay
you see an ocean can store heat in the
summer and release it during the winter
which results in a mild climate like you
needed another reason to live close to
the water
but hold on how would you even make it
all the way to Kepler-22b
I mean even if you were traveling at the
speed of light it would take you
635 years
your best bet could be to hibernate
through the trip inside a device that
preserves your body way past its natural
lifespan like cryogenic sleep
NASA has already developed a cryosleep
chamber that can lower an astronaut's
body temperature to as low as 32 degrees
Celsius
this would trigger natural hibernation
during which catheters would provide
your body with nutrients and remove any
waste
but even in cryosleep it would be quite
the long risky trip this leads us to the
most dangerous part about this journey
All That Remains Unknown about
Kepler-22b
for starters we still don't really know
what gravity is like there
could be twice as strong as our planets
if that was the case a 10 kilogram sack
of potatoes would now weigh 20 kilograms
and your body would also factor into the
mix
is your current weight 75 kilograms well
good luck suddenly dealing with 150
kilograms of you and just for safety
settlers such as yourself would need to
bulk up really bulk up
only through intense strength training
would you increase your chances of being
able to walk on Kepler-22b and once you
got jacked on Earth you'd have to figure
out ways to preserve that muscle through
all
635 years of light speed travel
but humans aren't the only life form
that would be affected by a stronger
gravity
plants brought from Earth for oxygen and
nutrition might not survive on
Kepler-22b when you try growing them
there and if you brought any animals
with you they'd need to step up the
evolution process
higher gravity could lead to creatures
developing additional legs to move
around it could also determine the
location and size of internal organs
but the Mysteries don't end there
scientists still don't know for sure
that Kepler-22b is even a rocky planet
it might be geishas similar to Neptune
or it could be entirely covered with
water
if you and the other first settlers woke
up from your cryo sleep and found
yourself on a gas planet
yeah that would be a downer
you wouldn't have a solid surface to
even land your ship not to mention a
place to set up camp
in that case you and your crew would
need to figure out how to build a cloud
city orbiting the planet
if you landed on an ocean planet a
submarine town would be in order
discovering Kepler-22b is a rocky planet
would be hitting the jackpot then right
well not so fast Venus is also made of
rock and yet its dense atmosphere
consisting of greenhouse gases makes it
uninhabitable with scorching
temperatures far too hot for liquid
water
if this was also the situation with
Kepler-22b our only chance at thriving
on this exoplanet would be to employ
robots that could build underground
shelters the place where maybe just
maybe the temperature might be cool
enough for you to bear
it just goes to show you that a prime
location is no guarantee for human
survival and as exciting as it might
seem to find other worlds to inhabit our
own Earth Remains the perfect Habitat
for Humanity
foreign
[Music]
if the largest country on Earth decided
it needs more territory and Power
well it might just go to war over it
what country could Russia invade first
what would be the plan of attack
and what's the most dangerous weapon in
Russia's possession
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Russia started a war
Russia already takes up one-eighth of
all the inhabited land on the planet and
now it has its eyes on one of its
European neighbors Ukraine
historically Ukraine and Russia have
been in conflicts before
most recently Russia annexed the
Ukrainian Peninsula Crimea and then it
backed a separatist rebellion in eastern
Ukraine
now Russia doesn't want Ukraine cozying
up to Nato
NATO out of Eastern Europe period
and even though Russia isn't a member of
NATO to make decisions on such things
with one of the most powerful militaries
in the world
Russia might feel like it can play by
its own rules
okay let's back up a little
first you might be wondering what NATO
is
well NATO is the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization and right now it includes
30 members the United States Canada
Netherlands and the United Kingdom are
among them
NATO's goal is to keep the peace and
make sure no member of this Alliance
gets invaded by an international
military force
you know like that time Russia took
Crimea from Ukraine
now Ukraine is not yet a member of NATO
but it has shown interest in joining it
and that doesn't sit well with Russian
President Vladimir Putin
Putin is already a little freaked out
that NATO is training Ukrainian troops
and some members are supplying its army
with weapons
so he's decided to go about it with the
good old method of persuasion he's
threatening to start a war
now with a defense budget of 42 billion
dollars Russia puts a lot of love and
money into its military
Russia's Army counts 3.5 million
recruits and it has tanks thirteen
thousand of them no other country in the
world has this many
Russia also has 27 000 armored vehicles
and ranks first in the world with its 4
465 artillery guns
and then there's also Russia's nukes to
worry about
all 6
257 of them
these can be launched from aircraft subs
or missiles but if Russia decided to
attack
chances are it wouldn't start on land
no the first strike would likely come
from the air
this could level electricity stations
and bridges obliterate Rail lines and
crippled the economy of any country
attacked in addition to this Russia's
naval fleet is nearly unmatchable
their nuclear-powered submarines alone
parked along a coastline could pose
enough of a threat to anyone thinking
about taking them on depending who the
targeted country is of course
if Russia attacked Ukraine NATO would
likely respond with heavy economic
sanctions but Russia has allies of its
own it's a member of the collective
security Treaty Organization or csto
this is a group of six former Soviet
States in a nato-like Alliance
it also has Cuba in its corner and if
things should get really testy Cuba
would be a key hub for Russian troops
looking to do some damage on U.S soil
yeah it's pretty scary when 100
000 Russian troops are standing on your
doorstep but this likely wouldn't be a
war to wipe out the country chances are
Russia has something to gain from it it
might be natural resources or political
Leverage
whatever it is the plan wouldn't be to
obliterate every Target in its way only
to do enough damage to make their point
in the case of Ukraine it could shut
down the Ukrainian economy but they
could do that with minimal forces on the
ground war is also not fought the same
way it was even a decade ago it can be
much more covert
hack attack anyone
Queen Elizabeth II has passed peacefully
in her Palm moral castle in Scotland
how will this affect the economy
what will it mean for the future of the
Commonwealth
and what does operation London Bridge
have to do with this
this is what if and here's what happens
when the queen dies
since 1952 the United Kingdom has lived
under the rule of Queen Elizabeth II
that makes her the longest reigning
monarch in British history
multiple Generations have never known
life with a different head of state
in the event of her passing there is a
well-established line of succession
the Queen's oldest son Charles Prince of
Wales will inherit the throne
but will Prince Charles have the support
of the British public
could the end of the Queen's Reign Mark
the end of the British royal family
for years information about what would
happen when the queen dies was kept
under very tight cover but these plans
are no longer Secret
on the day of this traumatic event
operation London Bridge would begin
a code name like this is not unique when
the Queen's father King George VI passed
away that plan was codenamed Hyde Park
corner operation London Bridge lays out
in exact detail what to do from the
moment of her death through 12 days of
national Mourning
first her private secretary would inform
the current prime minister
civil servants would say London Bridge
Is Down unsecure lines
the news of her passing would be shared
with the other 15 governments of which
she is the head of state and the 36
Commonwealth Nations for whom she served
as a symbolic figurehead
a footman in morning clothes would place
a notice on the gates of Buckingham
Palace informing the public of the news
all staff of the royal family would wear
a black armband on their left arm
this band must measure eight and a
quarter centimeters
from there Rats the radio alert
transmission system would be activated
This Cold War era alarm system was
designed to withstand attacks on the
nation's infrastructure
television coverage would begin the
media have their own nickname for this
situation Mrs Robinson
all the main channels would pull their
regular programming and presenters would
be wearing black
but with social media there's a good
chance you would learn it there first
news of the Queen's passing would
quickly pop up everywhere
it could sound morbid but the media has
days of coverage planned and content
including obituaries ready to go
if you happen to be on a plane at this
moment you'd hear the news from your
pilot
you wouldn't be able to watch any late
night comedy shows they wouldn't run
until after the Queen's funeral
the Queen's body would remain at
Buckingham Palace for 10 days and the
family would be spending time together
but for the new ruler there wouldn't be
much time for Mourning
the day after the Queen's death at 11 am
Prince Charles would be proclaimed King
on the 10th day officials from all
around the world would attend the
Queen's funeral at Westminster Abbey
this would be a massive day of mourning
and hundreds of thousands of people
would come to pay their respects even
the British stock market would remain
closed this day
a ceremonial decision that could cost
the economy billions of pounds
of course this plan accounts for what
happens if the queen passes away in
London but what if she happens to pass
away abroad
well there's a jet from the Royal Air
Force always ready to respond
it would carry the first call coffin to
bring the Queen's body back to London
after nearly 70 years in power life
under a new monarch could certainly lead
to changes around the Commonwealth
several Nations could decide to finally
break their ties to Britain and become
full republics the monarchs could even
be replaced with heads of state elected
on a rotating basis
but the plans for operation London
Bridge are as elaborate detailed and
controlled as the life of the Royal
Family
nothing is left a chance and that makes
it seem as though the future of the
monarchy remains strong
though in the wake of the death of the
Beloved Queen Elizabeth II everything
could change
you know sometimes people in power
refuse to abide by the rules
but
that's a story for another what if
you've been through it all this year
whether you're running from dinosaurs
avoiding asteroids or even fighting in
World War Three
the extreme possibilities we've explored
together are well extreme
with